-Guys, it is Tuesday.
It is time for WePost.
Let's play this game.
-♪ WePost ♪
♪♪
♪ WePost ♪
-Now this is "WePost."
This is where we,
as a group, decide something
that we should
all post on socials.
Actually, that I'm gonna post
on socials.
Okay, yeah. But I'm gonna show
you five different posts,
and we are all
going to vote on
whether you like
each one or not.
You all have voting clickers
at your seats?
All right, good. You can vote
for all of them, if you like.
You can vote for none of them,
if you like.
Whatever you want. We're going
to see the results live.
Higgins, Robert Glasper,
you guys have your clickers?
Everyone's got
their stuff ready to go?
All right. And I will say,
I will remind everyone,
not necessarily do they get
funnier as they go on.
-Right.
[ Laughter ]
-So if you feel like
it remotely has a shot,
yeah, why not?
Yeah, it's for fun, yeah.
-Some of these
are just sentences, right?
-Yes. I'm gonna post
whichever one
gets the most likes
from all of us
because it's not a me post.
It's a we post.
-Oh.
[ Cheering ]
All right.
You guys ready?
-Yeah!
-First post is...
[ Laughter ]
-"They were talking about you."
-"Why --
Why are they talking about me?
Why --
I'm trending."
[ Both laugh ]
All right, cast your votes.
Thumbs up or thumbs down.
All right. The votes are in.
Let's see the results
for this first one here.
Not bad. Okay.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not good.
Not good, either, but not bad.
Yeah. No.
All right.
This next one says...
-Oh.
Wow.
[ Laughter ]
That did not sound
like they liked that one.
-I mean, I thought I liked it,
but, no.
-No, apparently not.
-Now I'm gonna vote no
on this one.
-Sounds like they made
that whole joke
out of the first bite.
-No. Yeah. All right. Good.
Yeah. All right, let's see.
I don't even know if I want
to see the results on this one.
-Do you want to see this one?
-I don't really want to see it,
but let's do it.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, my...
[ Audience exclaims ]
At least you know
the clickers work.
[ Laughter ]
Wow!
-38.
-Wow.
Let me know how you really feel.
Yeah.
Oh, my gosh.
I think that first bite
is delicious.
-Sure.
So is the rest of the pizza.
-Yeah, that's true.
[ Laughter ]
It is true.
It doesn't quite make sense.
All right.
This next one says...
[ Laughter ]
-Come on, that's a good one.
Come on.
♪♪
Mom...
-I don't know.
It can't get much worse
than the pizza one.
All right, let's see
the results here.
Oh, yeah, that's very nice.
Thank you.
[ Cheers and applause ]
People being ni--
People were being nice.
-Yeah.
-People were being very nice.
-Humorous.
-That's how great this city is.
They come together
when they see --
When they see
that you're hurting,
they're right there for you.
They go, "Jimmy, come here."
-Then they kick you
while you're down.
-"It's not that bad.
That pizza one was bad,
but, come on,
we're there for you."
I appreciate that, guys.
This next one here says...
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
I don't know.
I'm doing it to be nice.
I don't know if this is --
Let's see the results here.
Yeah, yeah, I agree.
[ Audience "Oohs" ]
-[ Laughs ]
-Tartar sauce walked...
-No, I could tell immediately,
they were like,
"No, we were nice,
and now we're being real."
[ Laughter ]
I appreciate it.
I totally agree with you.
This last one, I feel like
this one might do it.
-This one's a good one.
-Well, I don't know about that,
but I think this one might
be the one that wins.
-Okay.
-Yeah.
What was the other one
that we have so far in the lead?
-Doc Marten.
-Doc Marten, emo boots.
That's funny. Yeah.
-Medical degree.
-This one mi--
This is the last one.
If you like it, let me know.
If you don't...
Well, you know...
You already have
let me know. Okay.
Last one is...
[ Laughter ]
I feel you.
-Come on.
I'm kind of feeling.
-No, I'm feeling good
about this one.
I think this one
might be a winner.
I feel good.
-It's going to be high.
-Let's see the results
right here.
-Whoa!
-Oh, yeah!
We have a winner right there!
Come on, now!
[ Ding! ]
Futon! I'm gonna post this
during the break.
If you happen
to see it online,
give that WePost a repost.